oh
sorry that's all i can say after
watching that they didn't actually put a
real helmet there on the ground and
filmed it we're seeing a bit of a
distortion here that isn't physically
accurate to what the helmet that would
actually do mark hamill was filmed he
was actually there they didn't use any
of it
today's episode is brought to you by
raycon stick around to the end to see
how you can get 15 off your pair of
premium wireless earbuds
welcome back to another episode of
visual effects artist react we're here
on the couch with nico and sam i'm very
excited about some of the stuff that
we're going to be looking at today did
you guys ever see the clip from star
trek where they stabilized all the
camera shakes
can you pull it up real quick christian
shields
look at that grip he's got on the chair
though
it's like if the ship moves this much
every time it's shot
[Applause]
anyway so disney came out with the
behind the scenes the mandalorian where
they took a look at how they did the
effects for the digital luke skywalker
and if you remember back in january we
took our own crack at this with some
deep fakes
it was an amazing time doing that video
i mean hey mark hamill he not only
watched our video he had some
constructive criticism about our
marketing attitude yeah having a little
bit of just arrogance by being like we
beat disney and then mark hamill's all
like maybe you shouldn't say that
he did not grant us the rank of master
and we were like what and he's like you
need to learn humility and like okay
mark hamill did personally respond to
dean and that totally made dean's month
year i don't know like his eyes were
getting watery there's a crew cuts
episode about it but that's the kind of
righteous dude that mark hamill is the
luke skywalker effect you know that's
ballsy to go out and do a shot like that
for a show like this the amount of time
they have and you know the amount of
resources they can throw at it it's not
at all like a giant feature film not a
lot of time to just recreate something
that's going to be scrutinized by
millions of people so we took our
guesses at how they did the dh luke
skywalker but they were all just guesses
so now they just dropped the behind the
scenes and they cover how they did that
effect so let's see how close we were to
getting it right
so first off mark hamill was filmed he
was actually there doesn't mean they
used him for the actual shot my guess is
that they didn't use any of it i think
it was probably just for moral support
for the crew and post team but also just
inspiration for like what should this
moment look like from the man himself we
always talk about shooting reference
it's like oh you're gonna put explosion
and have a real explosion or something
like that you know to reference and like
this is the same thing for acting if
you're going to play a young luke
skywalker get the man who played luke
skywalker to show you how to do it yeah
the amount of morale uplift from having
the loose skyrockers set it just
motivates them to up their own game so i
think it's even though it's intangible
you get this overall lift in quality
that's hard to measure just by having
his presence
oh interesting so they're actually deep
faking the third luke skywalker onto the
first luke skywalker because mark hamill
is actually kind of a very different
person between the first and third star
wars movies and so what we're seeing
right here is they're experimenting by
taking the third one and putting it on
the first one there's all their face
extraction sets
hey we should y'all want to rip that
wow they have all this archival footage
to use dude they got like the original
like outtakes and whatnot so much so
much data that they can just have
with where deep fake technology was at
that point it was it was felt as though
you know we really needed to kind of
rely a little bit more on the tried and
true techniques so they backed off a
deep fix interesting so does this mean
they went with lola to actually do a lot
of this then lola did the lola did the
effect i mean lola is pretty much the
leading master at de-aging technology
we've talked about lola and their
de-aging effects on episodes in the past
they're very good at it so it's still
very confusing they're like so we did a
bunch of defects stuff and then we tried
a bunch of different other stuff using
this other actor
i think i think this is the closest
we're going to get to seeing how they
did it
[Laughter]
like wow
did you do there's like 20 passes
happening
oh my gosh
maybe did they start with a deep fake
and then just augment it to high heaven
that's a deep face yeah we can tell
because of the way like the peripheral
of that square is like kind of generated
it's got that weird like painterly look
to it that is just ai just like
fill it so it is a deep fake
kind of
it's a defect with about 30 layers of
nuke on top of it yeah so there's a lot
of nuance to what is happening in this
behind the scene because they're not
going to go deep into this and tell you
that mark hamill didn't play young luke
skywalker but they are pointing out that
they did have mark hamill on set both as
a respect for what he's brought to the
character as well as a way to show that
he was involved in actually directing
this other actor to give us a loose
skywalker it's not like they're just you
know somehow generating a 3d model of
mark campbell's face going whoop and
like making it younger and sticking it
back on the other actor it's really just
for reference i think the only actual
thing in the final product that you're
seeing is they filmed the young actor
who's taking his cues from both the
director as well as mark hamill
and they looks like they did a deep fake
they're then going in layering and
layering and layering and layering a
whole bunch of hand-based compositing on
top of it which
really does help take the deep fake to a
level that works for television and
high-end you know film
but it also kind of disrupts the
photorealism of it because when an
artist has to go in and put 30 you know
brushstrokes on by hand it's not going
to be that mathematically perfect
computer algorithm spitting out an image
it's going to be the interpretation of a
bunch of different compositing artists
but it also looks crisp it looks clean
there's no bugs it's not like his you
know his teeth have melded into one
giant white bar in his mouth his eyes go
up every once in a while like in our old
tom cruise deep fake hey what's up guys
does it look like a photoreal young luke
skywalker no but it looks great huge
props to them for actually doing a deep
fake like all the mandalorian is just
like you know pioneering visual effects
stuff the volume capture like i bet you
this would be so much more deep fake
luke skywalker in the next season oh
yeah ilm actually hired shamook one of
the leading deep fake artists on the
internet to continue their deep fake
research which like
literally is like
that was the best move they could have
possibly made like that was a smart
decision because you know even if you
don't use your deep fakes for the final
effect it is amazing reference they
actually do this for the irishman where
they basically created an ai that would
pull out faces of robert de niro from a
whole library of movies and give you the
angle and the lighting to pick like put
against the shot with your cg head so
you can look at the real thing and the
cg thing and see how close they were so
even if you're not using it it's still
an awesome reference to have props to
the team for actually releasing this
because if like the amount of views this
show gets is any sign of people's
interest in how films are made i think
you know like we need more of this
absolutely it's it's it's so rough each
time we see something super cool and
have to basically guess how things are i
mean they're educated guesses but it's
so nice to be able to actually watch the
behind the scenes with you guys and
actually break it down together john
favreau and dave filoni and all the
whole rest of the team on the
mandalorian are just doing an amazing
job with this show
surprise hey guys how's it going i hope
you're enjoying the episode well we've
got a bonus secret scene available just
on the website cordovdigital.com
okay enjoy the rest of the episode i'm
gonna get back down here bye
this is suicide well that's kind of our
thing so this movie's great there's
great visual effects all over the place
and so on twitter someone tagged me in a
question to james gunn saying hey how
did you do this shot and i was like
i know
it's a true
creative use of visual effects and live
action footage
then we got michael cena
michael ceda he was an arrested
development michael cena
oh god dang it
so here we go
oh yeah look at that that's uh that's a
helmet that's chrome where you don't see
any sort of camera in the reflections
and you can even see the shadows of them
moving around a little bit on the ground
yeah a little bit as they're nearby it
yeah they didn't actually put a real
helmet there on the ground and filmed it
because then you'd have to paint out the
camera and obviously the camera would
then be blocking the entire scene
happening directly behind the camera
there is a classic issue when you are
making a film and you have to deal with
reflective objects it's like how do you
hide the camera and the crew and all
that stuff you know you look at the the
sunglasses in the matrix you know and
very frequently some people just like
wearing like a black cloak over their
head you know and a tiny lens is sitting
there and you just hope that it's you're
dark enough to not be seen this is the
ultimate challenge of space movies you
think zero gravity is a tough visual
effect try taking camera out of every
space man's reflective visor exactly
right
they just throw out a 360 camera and
then map the reflection onto a 3d object
i think it was even easier than that
they could have used a 360 camera but
i'm willing to bet they straight up had
the scene play out with an actual cinema
camera on the ground looking up at them
that they can then just project out onto
a dome that we then see rendered out as
a reflection so it's like we got the
camera filming a scene that scene is
then placed in 3d space with a digital
camera than looking at the helmet which
is reflecting the actual filmed element
behind it so everything that we're
seeing here is very easy to do
not gonna lie
i say it's easy to do but they excelled
at making this good for a lot of like
the small details like the actual proper
distortion of the helmet it's not
perfectly round there's actually like
some rippling to it
the the actual environmental shadows on
the ground around the helmets we're
seeing a bit of a distortion here that
isn't physically accurate to what the
helmet would actually do
if you were filming a reflection
the bloom would not be in the reflection
outside you know just maybe some surface
imperfections or smearing on the surface
the bloom happens and the light enters
the lens of the camera so if you look at
john cena there's bloom wrapping around
him from that light that's an effect
that happens when light hits the lens of
the camera it's not an effect that
happens on the surface of the helmet
unless you have smears per se that's a
different kind of bloom than like the
glow of light going into a camera lens
oh you see it on the light on the right
too like as it starts curving with the
reflection you see
the bloom starts curving which wouldn't
be how that light would actually go that
being said it doesn't take away it does
not at all this is like that's such a
nitpicky thing for
at the end of the day the most important
part of this entire shot is the fight
between those two guys and keeping the
viewers in the moment while also having
a kick-ass shot yeah the effects are
great it's a great movie the action's
awesome
hey so i would like your suggestion for
movies that we should revisit and talk
about other scenes in so we've talked
about a lot of movies in the show is
there anything we should go back to and
revisit a different scene from please
leave a suggestion down below dude i i
honestly really want to look at pirates
of the caribbean again you looked at
davey jones and then the guy who
actually made davey jones eyes reached
out to us is like you did it wrong
yeah
so a big movie that we've never actually
taken a look at is war of the worlds
from 2005 starring tom cruise and
directed by steven spellberg this movie
kind of got greenlit and put into
production like very rapidly like steven
spielberg and tom cruise their schedule
just happened to line up so i was like
oh we're doing a movie and they
basically had to have the movie made in
like less than a year and so in order to
make that happen ilm had to work really
quickly and ended up becoming the
tightest deadline in ilms history for
like four or 500 shots they only had a
few months to do everything so this was
the first movie steven spielberg used
previz instead of storyboards for and so
that they're able to kind of get a good
idea of the pacing and layout of the
movie ahead of time so that in
conjunction with filming
the artists at ilm could start
developing assets start planning out
shots
that's crazy looking right
those are digital effects like that's
cgi that's amazing cgi physics sims i
recently rewatched this and just like
that blew my mind it looks great so good
classic blockbusters might show this
from a very different angle and yet
we're seeing it from a very challenging
perspective there is no motion control
on this set it's all very just organic
handheld motion dude the edge blur is so
strong in this movie right now though
honestly for how good everything is the
edge feather is like unfortunately just
janky it is so extreme like this guy
right here
and then also when he's like running
away from the house blowing up and stuff
this is like probably
the most iconic shot from the entire
movie so much so that it was like the
shot used in the super bowl commercial
damn looks so good damn look at his
physics sims
boom
sorry that's all i can say after
watching that do you see the houses
freaking lift
like there's a moment right before the
bloom hits it's like yeah look at that
it's like like you're saying the physics
sims
are incredible
is there like are you about to like
turns out they're models
yeah it was all miniature work
wait what
that's so cool
because like these days you can
replicate that level of detail with like
a houdini sim and a lot of time and
rendering sure but you know back then
this is you know 2004 that they're
working on it 2005 that it came out they
didn't have the tools that could do that
level of you know destruction the bridge
was a miniature no you pointed out the
one cg element the bridge was cg the
cars on the bridge were cg all of the
houses and all the debris that you're
seeing was actual like exploded model
work i cannot believe it and then of
course all of the digital compositing
that goes into bring all this together i
am so spoiled by cg to think that
there's no way you could get that high
detail of a house explosion with
miniatures because usually when you see
miniatures you're like okay usually
they're cool but they don't have that
like every plank of a house kind of just
just barfing wood and debris kind of
feeling that's usually something you see
with a complex like physics simulation
in cg so for that
bridge shot what was crazy about it is
that they literally came up with the
idea for it shot it finished it all in a
month so that they could deliver it for
the super bowl commercial it's a great
shot it's so dynamic this is like the
epitome of what an amazing shot looks
like
there's one more shot that i think blew
me away when i saw it because it was a
oner and what i mean by that is
basically just one long continuous shot
as this car is driving down the highway
i think something like nine different
shots were married together for the
sequence that ends up being two and a
half minutes long there was a lot that
went into this so let's try to consider
everything that is involved for a shot
like this first they're filming these
guys in a car on a blue screen cg
reflections on glass yeah all of the
glasses cg all of the reflections on the
glass have to be rendered out they even
have little subtle things like all of
like the the schmutz on the windshield
just out of the eyeline of the actors
yeah but enough to be there to be like
there's a windshield but also all of the
background footage what they actually
did was they put a bunch of cameras on i
think like a jeep or something like that
and literally just like drove it down
the road capturing background plates
from a bunch of different angles that
they're putting in the background of
each of these shots so i don't know what
kind of stretch of road they have but
i'm willing to bet they probably are
reusing the same stretch of road for
different parts of the sequence right
there's the bus again the bus repeated
itself they have scooby dude themselves
rachel they've helped me
i
and then of course then it ends and then
it flawlessly transitions to a real van
driving off into the distance this is
just such classic spielberg here you
know where it's like he's making a
dynamic setup but it's focused on the
characters and their struggles all the
fancy stuff we're seeing is just
supplementary to what we're actually
focusing on
brandi o'daniel back here with the next
clip on this react episode courtesy of
today's sponsor raycon let's just jump
into it okay pull up the clip
yeah okay as you can see in this clip
this is the raycon earbud right here the
first thing you might not know is that
raycon is disrupting the electronics
industry by designing premium wireless
audio for half the price and without
compromise raycons offer the same
quality as almost any other premium
wireless earbud on the market but for
about half the price
yeah it does look very comfortable yeah
i can see that it fits right in the ear
so conveniently you can run you can go
to the gym you can work from home you
can you can go out and about in these
things or just do anything with them
recon offers a variety of fun colors and
styling options for the earbuds that
they have so you can get them to match
with any outfit any style any color
recon earbuds give you eight hours of
play time per charge and 32 hours of
total battery life they give you
seamless bluetooth pairing more bass
they also have a built-in microphone so
you can take any calls that you need
whether you're on the go or whether
you're at home and they come in a
compact convenient carrying case raycon
also has a 45-day free return policy so
if you don't like what you got just go
ahead and send them back for free guys
if you're interested in getting a pair
of raycons for yourself click the link
in the description below or go to
byraycon.com
quarter crew and you will get 15 off
your purchase that's 15 off your
purchase by going to byraycon.com
corridor crew guys thanks for letting me
do this i really appreciate it that was
that was a really fun one i can't wait
till next time when i get to do my
another jake special here on react um
here on quarter digital's vfx artists
react anyways
until next time
thank you so much for watching hey guess
what if you liked this and you want to
see more of this specific episode we
have an extended cut of this that is on
our website quarterdigital.com we got we
got a free trial no big deal if you like
it great if you don't well you always
got us here
it's time to
go
say goodbye see you later there were
three now there's two
it's time for me see you guys later
now there's one little lovely run
what happened to all my friends